you guys have met
probably a lot of your heroes like in
your line of work like who's just been
the coolest
the coolest yeah
brad pitt was crazy was super cool yeah
yeah brad pitt was super cool leonardo
dicaprio was super cool i've never met
him i don't think he is really into
animals and he came up to me i
i hope i i guess i didn't tell this
story so i was at some event and um he
came up to me and i didn't know it was
him and um he asked me about like wild
boy he's like you're from wow boys and
um i talked to him for like an hour
about like and all this animal stuff and
all that and i was like oh that guy was
real cool and then later on in the night
like i saw him like going on his way
home and he's with some gnarly model
girl i was like whoa that dude has a
gnarly girlfriend you didn't know lynn's
probably gizelle or something like
yeah i didn't and then the next day my
friends like yeah when you were talking
to leo last night and i was like that
was leonardo dicaprio i was like whoa i
had no idea wow like i'm not very good
at knowing if people are stars like but
he was super cool what was brad pitt
like he was rad
so [ __ ] cool what year was this dude
it was 2001. yeah that was 2000. legends
of the fall [ __ ]
around that time yeah 2001 and um
spike jones was buddies with brad pitt
and so they were like hanging out and
brad was like dude i want to be on
jackass like really like huh
and uh and so spike set it up
and and there was like a tv office that
we had and brad pitt's just just hanging
out just hanging out i remember like i
bumped a cigarette off of him
like he gave me a cigarette crazy he
smokes i was so surprised he smoked and
that movie 12 monkeys to get his
character he said he'd stop smoking
cigarettes to just get really [ __ ]
antsy
and act like he was in a mental ward god
yeah he was super cool like
yo go ahead like
he gave me a cigarette right around like
right in that in that same sort of
moment
i uh had my skateboard and i and i went
to go do this super difficult like fast
plant finger flip trick and i pulled it
off
like in front of brad in front of bad
brad pitt i did my most difficult trick
and i pulled it first time and i was
just like i remember like the first
thing he said to me too he was like hey
how long did how long did it take uh for
your eyebrows to grow it back when they
waxed them off wow that's weird he's a
fan yeah he did super cool dude he's so
cool you guys did you like kidnapped him
for the show and you did the monkey
thing right all right we have one we did
two bits one was we uh put him in line
at pink's which is this hot dog stand
that just always has the craziest line
and uh
kidnapped him
so funny which the cops that we called
the cops ahead of time set it up with
the police okayed it with them right
yeah they said disregard they knew to
disregard calls about brad pitt being
people were freak like trying to save
brad freaking out like this one dude was
like pulling back really hard right i
know ryan kingman was there filling with
it like
like and it was god like bam was so
pissed about the monkey suit thing and
he made a good point he's like you have
brad [ __ ] pit why
on earth are you going to put a [ __ ]
monkey put him in a monkey suit and
cover his face yeah it's like it could
be anybody i got it i know i thought he
had why did they do the punchline was
that with the credits when it's like um
it said like people yeah it was like
brad pitt and the monkey thing and then
he takes his the mask off and he's brad
pitt oh so when you first see his name
you're like oh that's obviously not brad
pitt i think that's any right it was a
bad idea so people were trying to save a
monkey not brad pitt no no no
monkey [ __ ] it was an extension of this
bit that i did before that where i just
ran around town like like um like
causing trouble just as a monkey and i i
swung on this flagpole
you remember that there's a flight
police i swung over traffic that was
from this thing that natas um did in
transworld like where uh he was swinging
over like a car do you remember that
picture
i
i
remember a lot of nadas i don't remember
uh but i guess uh spike took that
picture and he so he knew where this
flagpole was oh it was amazing
um but um
i'm fascinated with like different
celebrities and like asking people who
the meanest one and who the coolest one
was i can i can tell you who the meanest
one i ever met uh-oh her name is ellen
degeneres
it's crazy that all this stuff's come
out like about ellen being mean because
when i met her i thought she was really
mean like
why'd you meet her i met her at the vh1
bigano four or big no five awards
and um it was when her show was like
i guess she was the the big thing at the
time and all the like her sitcom or her
ellen show the ellen show or the the one
where she like in her yeah her talk show
so she was there and um i guess i was in
the green room and there wasn't that
many people in the green room like and
um so everyone like got to talking
pretty good and like someone like warned
her that like one of the toilets was
broken because it was like these kind of
like those fancy outdoor toilets and she
was like just give a really rude
response and then she was just smoking
cigarettes like in her heart
yeah i was so surprised she was smoking
and she's like so what do i got to do
like and she just pissed to be there and
then she comes out on stage and she's
like all like funny nice ellen you know
like that the person that they think she
is so i talked to her and um i she had
no interest in talking to me at all she
was
like and yeah she i don't know she
seemed to hate me but then she seemed
just to hate everyone so i wasn't
surprised when everyone came forward
saying that ellen is a tyrant
yeah well what about working with
britney spears did you both uh green she
was perfectly she was cool super nice
she was perfectly sweet and if anything
she was just i thought britney spears
was insulated by like
people trying to keep you away from her
but like if you could get to her she's
down
super nice yeah and it was crazy because
remember there was a helicopter flying
above just because they knew that
britney spears was out there filming
really all right paparazzi helicopter
yeah that's next level that is next
level like especially like what does it
cost to get a helicopter up in the air
you know it's not a drone yeah it's a
[ __ ]
like i could tell you what yeah
wow to maybe get a photo that's a huge
investment what about working with kim
kardashian
she was cool as hell i heard she was
nice yeah yeah she's she's uh
super super laid back like you know i've
met kim kardashian a bunch of times yeah
i've heard i've always heard she was
really nice yeah who have you met that
wasn't so nice um lindsay lohan no
lindsay lohan was always super sweet to
me
i i partied with her a lot okay i've
heard some of those party stories yeah
yeah lindsay lohan i partied with her a
lot one time she came over to my
apartment and uh was a lot immediately
locked herself up in the bathroom
like with like one of her friends
and then it turned out that
she had left her wallet in my bathroom
at my apartment so she reached out
to try to try to get her her wallet back
now meanwhile while she was at my
apartment i pulled out a video camera on
her and like just filmed some stuff that
made her like pretty uncomfortable and
uh
then the next day she's like hey i left
my wallet can you bring it to me
and uh i [ __ ]
brought her back her wallet and made her
sign a release for him for the footage
i traded her i was like
yeah here's your weight like here's your
wallet but can you decide
because you were gonna use it in like
one of your own videos yeah i wanted to
use it in one of my own videos it wasn't
anything like that bad it wasn't
anything that bad but it just also was
like i just stuck a camera in her face
and it was
i've seen the footage i think at the
time it's like she was like a paparazzi
you know it was when she was afraid upon
yeah so any like her partying like for
you to pull out a camera like this is
the last thing i want to see i think
that's when she started hiding in the
bathroom
because of you
yeah and then you're like you're like
lindsay i want to show you a trick with
this knife on my nose or something like
that she just refused to come out
yeah
um did you told me a story about like
partying with her in new york and like
her having like two suvs and like
bodyguards and like muscling people out
of the bathroom so
like
yeah there's a little bit a little bit
of that i don't know if these are
private stories
um maybe yeah yeah maybe you should
avoid those
yeah yeah then i'm not gonna i i well
i'll say this there was uh at some point
i feel like it was in the news that
she had like a list of
there was something that got like leaked
and it came out and it was like in her
handwriting and it was like
she had written a list of like famous
men that she had been in bed with yeah
and uh
i i
she hadn't she had mentioned some of
that i remember you telling me telling
me about asking her about them and like
who was the best and like throughout the
smallest leader she yeah she she did
critique yeah
is there a best we can get or any sort
of
yeah i'll leave it at that fair enough
but wait to for chris's question
who was the least cool celebrity you met
for me the least cool and not because
you were being like annoying or right
right right right
take all those out oh well then everyone
was pretty cool
yeah who was the who's the guy that you
got into vegas mike ness and he or she
he was that guy he he wasn't uncool at
all i remember i mean dude like i'm
always annoying or at least i was really
annoying and i remember kid rock was
with pamela anderson and like
again there was like 2001
and i was like yo dude oh man let me
show you this trick i mean i'm just
tricking i'm like balancing the cup and
i'm trying to lay down and like he just
[ __ ] kicked me
he just straight kicked me and knocked
the cup off my head ruined my trick
oh i remember like i might have been at
this party like we went to like some it
was like stuff magazine or one of those
men's magazines yeah and then after we
went to like the after party and like i
saw i remember seeing kid rock with his
chick i thought that was like this
gnarly like stripper looking girl and
once again i didn't recognize the the
star it was pamela anderson yeah but i
was blown away by how like that was that
was actually where there was a santa
monica pier yeah [ __ ] stuff magazine
party that was where kid rock kicked me
yeah in the middle of my trip
in the middle of my trick well you do
you just go to people and be like let me
show you a trick
you need to go to caprio can i show you
a trick that's what he did to everyone
not even celebrities though when we
first met him yeah oh dude i remember
like what was your go-to trick
though i balance the cup on my head and
join me without touching with my hair
would you want to show people that just
yeah but dude i remember a lot of people
were not [ __ ] stoked i remember perry
farrell from jane's addiction he was in
the middle there's way before even
jackass
and uh and like a crowded nightclub and
he's trying to just navigate his way
through the crowd and i'm like yeah dude
he hated it and uh and they would watch
the whole trick and like cool and uh and
prince was super a jerk to me i remember
i was like i was like oh prince prince
do you don't let me let me show you a
trick and so i'm doing my trick
and i had uh
this model girlfriend and and he turns
to my my mother girlfriend he's like
does this impress you
like you said it in a real condescending
dig way and you were famous by this time
all right yeah yeah and uh and my model
girlfriend said yeah it's actually
pretty pretty impressive you should you
should check it out it's me and he was
just
but yeah but chris makes a very good
point that like
like i i definitely inspired a lot of
people to be jerks to me
perhaps perhaps you set them up
but i remember uh one of the first or
second nights we ever hung out like we
were at the hotel that we were staying
at in miami for jackass and we were
climbing on like the balcony or
something the security guy
guard like rolls up on a golf cart and
he's like hey you guys got to get down
and you're like dude it's cool and you'd
like jump down you did like you like did
a press to handstand for him like show
that it was cool
he's like yeah you did that for me
before at a bar and i bought your drinks
you know what
i think the word might be incorrigible
well we talked about when your sister
was on the show we talked about how when
your parents would have guests over they
would make you and cindy come perform
tricks for them like perform for them
that's do you think that like that's
possible to you when you meet someone
you want to show them a trick that's
like your go-to instinct
and i think it could be from that it
very well could be it's that's that's
insightful i would think that when i was
editing it i was like oh my god yeah
maybe that's where it comes from let me
swim 100 laps for a dollar for you yeah
it's like a new person like a new friend
like let me show you a trick let me
perform yeah what am i that's heavy dude
yeah i mean dude
and let me say too like
having watched our first episode
like i [ __ ] i'm so grateful for you
dude
i mean i just [ __ ] love you so much
man and uh particularly as we reflect on
what an annoying douche i've been over
the years like uh you are
unwavering love and support of me i love
you too and and and i didn't think you
were being a no you were annoying
i think i think but i yeah when i said
that like it was maybe the celebrities
might have taken you as as aggressive i
i like i i i can be a lot to handle
overly friendly yeah my problem is too
that what like the more a person excites
me the more amplified my approach to
them is yeah so it's kind of like like
people stutter when it's most important
for them to not stutter right like i'm
getting bigger articulate i'm the
biggest douche when it should be
important to me to not be a douche right
no but you're like when we have
something on the podcast that you really
want to have on like you're really
like articulate you know i'm sure the
drugs and alcohol didn't help at all the
case but like when you have somebody
here like you you're not overzealous or
anything like that like you just
it takes you a little bit longer to get
to the point but like you don't you
don't go crazy no yeah you're not so
much this way now the way that we're
just wrong
i've never known you like that
since i've known you you know oh yeah
that you were just excited you were just
happy to be there yeah you know the
people and at least you were nice you
know the worst people are the people
not the big celebrities like brad pitt
or leonardo dicaprio it's always those
fly by night celebrities that like are
like big one day and then gone the next
that think they're like the biggest deal
in town like those are the ones like the
situation that guy wasn't he
he he was uh he was a jerk to me the
situation yep yeah
i didn't like your trick
[Laughter]
it was on the the was it an mtv awards
the mtv vmas or no sorry it was the mtv
music award mtv movie awards and we were
there to promote jackass 3d
and uh like i went up to the situation
on the red carpet and you're sober i was
sober
and i went up to the situation
and uh he cool guided me i forget i
forget what he's too cool though he
snubbed you he was too cool he snubbed
me you're like i might have been i think
i might have been barging into his
interview and interrupted
i haven't seen anything of that guy
since that comedy special like
i wasn't on that one i wasn't on the one
but he was on the roast
trump
perhaps it was it was pretty gnarly it
was just it was pretty gnarly bomb
and uh and and certainly he yeah he
really bombed
however
i'm not trying to
beat up on him too much you know i i
think uh how how were all the stars when
you did the the celebrity roast were
they all i mean pretty cool
they were super cool
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]